Jesus called people fools and idiots.
You still don't believe me? All right,
man. I get tired when I have to do this.
But guys, give me a few minutes because
I want to wrap it up. All right, let's
see. When he calls people fools. Fools.
Mori. He calls them fools.
Fools. What's the word fool? Stupid.
It's the word Jesus called people
stupid morons.
Matthew 23:17.
Matthew 23:17. The word mori moros is
where you get What does it mean?
Stupid. You stupid
Dull or stupid. Blockhead.
Moronic. Mentally inert.
Stupid. Foolish.
Wait. What did Jesus call people? Right
here. Matthew. You stupid morons.
This gives you a complete new
perspective on the Bible, right? And
what true love is, right?
What true love is. If Jesus is God and
he is and he is love, source of love,
then you cannot tell me it is
uncristlike, unloving to insult people
when love almighty,
infinite love became flesh. Jesus is a
love in the flesh and he's calling
people stupid, morons, idiots,
right? Am I missing something here?
Am I missing something here?
If Jesus is God, and he is, and God is
love, he defines love. He's the source
of love. Then how is it that love who
became flesh is calling people stupid,
morons, idiots,
dogs?
I'm going to throw you up at Jesus, man.
Thank you, Father. Thank you, Lord,
Jesus. Thank you, Holy Spirit. And it's
the same way in the Old Testament
through Jeremiah. He says, "My children,
Israel, they're stupid." He says,
"They're stupid."
So, let's end it here. Final one.
All right. Right here. Luke 11.
By the way, you've heard this before. If
you've been following me for a while,
this is not new, but we're creature
repetition. We need to hear something
repetitively until it becomes
second nature. How many of you have been
shocked and continue to be shocked and
are refreshed to see this form of
Christianity which is not sisified
effeminate Christianity but it's a bold
Christianity bold and that love doesn't
conflict with insulting rebuking and
reprimanding people. How many of you are
actually excited to see what the Bible
actually teaches about these things?
This is how Christianity has always been
until the rise of a feminite
Christianity,
right?
Why do you think people are drawn to
harsh personality types that are
extreme? Nick Fuentes or Andrew Tate
because boys and men are sick of being
emasculated and being told this is what
Christianity is. That men act like
effeminite cowards
right
now. Let's finish it. Now when he had
spoken Luke 11:37:52
Jesus politically incorrect a fairy as
asked them to have a meal with him went
in and reclined at the table. When the
fairy saw it he marveled that he had not
first similarly washed before the meal.
He didn't wash his hands. He was not
politically correct nor did he follow
social norms or taboss.
Just went to eat. He didn't go wash his
hands. But the Lord said to him, "Now
you Pharisees, now look, look at the
Lord. straight shooter in your face, not
politically correct. The Pharisee,
a hypocrite,
made a big deal over the fact that
Christ did not wash his hands. And Jesus
says, "You're worried about not washing
hands, whereas your inside, you're dead,
and you're filthy. Why don't you worry
about cleaning your insides?" Straight
to the point.
in his own house,
in his own home.
Now you Pharisees clean the outside a
cup of the flatter, but inside of you,
you are full of robbery, wickedness. In
his house, a man who invited him to eat
when he made a big deal and he was
shocked Jesus and washed his hands.
You're worried about me not washing my
hands. You're full of filth inside.
You are dead inside. You're decrepit
inside. Why don't you wash your inside
and don't worry about the outside
right?
You see it here in his house. Can you
imagine? You invite someone and he
insults you in your house and
embarrasses you in front of others and
puts you in your place in front of
others in your house.
In your own house.
If I did that, you'll say, "Man, this
guy's no Christian. This guy's a fake.
He's a disgrace to Christianity."
That means you just condemn Jesus,
right? You foolish ones. Oh, there's
that word again. You stupid morons in
the guy's house. He called the guy in
his house and his guest stupid morons.
Really? Let's see.
I'm going to also include the title
about insulting people.
There you go. In the guy's house. Huh?
Can you imagine I call you a stupid
in your house? Afron.
Let's see what it means. Afron.
Foolish. Senseless. Unwise,
mindless, stupid, ignorant.
So he calls people morons, stupid,
senseless idiots,
properly mindless, meaning you have no
mind, stupid, ignorant, egotistic, rash,
unbelieving, fool,
right? Shortsighted, right?
Be honest with me. When's the last time
you had any Bible study unpack
what true love is and show you Jesus who
is perfect true love in the flesh,
showing you at times the most loving
thing is to insult people and not tickle
ears. When's the last time you had this
happen? So, you're like a stupid animal.
Senseless animal. Foolish and stupid.
Don't think
Honestly, guys.
So, wait. How would you feel if I walked
in your house and I called you stupid,
idiot, hypocrite? You're more
concerned about washing your hands, but
inside your soul you're decrepit and
filthy. What would you say to me?
What would you say to me?
There you go. You foolish ones. Did not
he who made the outside make the inside
also? Give that which is within as
charity, right? Love, and then all
things are clean for you. But woe to you
Pharisees, you for you pay the tithe of
mint. You even tithe on mint, man. You
follow the letter of the rule of the
law. Ruin every kind of gardener yet
describe disregard justice and the love
of God. You filthy hypocrite.
But these are the things you should have
done without neglecting others. What do
you Pharisees? For you love the best
seat in the synagogues and the
respectful greetings in the marketplace.
Look how bad it's going to get. You want
the highest places. You want the finest
seats. You want the highest position.
You want people to recognize your
greatness.
You hypocrites.
Now look,
woe to you for you are like concealed
tombs. The people walk over them are
unaware of it. They don't know you're
dead. You're spiritually dead. You're a
grave waiting to bury someone cuz you
look like you're alive. You fake.
Right. Watch here. Look how bad bad it
gets.
Now, one of the scholars of the law
answered and said to him, "A lawyer, by
the way, teacher, when you say these
things, you assault us, too." Jesus,
reminder, you just offended these
lawyers.
They feel hurt.
You're being insensitive. Remember,
Galatians 5:22-23.
Remember 1 Corinthians 13, love.
If you have faith to move mountains, you
don't have love. You're like a gong.
Remember Jesus?
What did Jesus say to them?
What did Jesus say to them? Look,
they're insulted, right? You You're
hurting us, Jesus. You're including us.
You just called us stupid idiots. Why?
You're insulting us. Oh, did he say,
"Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't get the memo."
Galatians 5:22. You know, because Paul's
going to write it later, but he said,
"Woe to you too, you scholars of law.
You too. You're no better in their own
home.
In their own home, huh?
But he said, "Woe to you scholars of law
as well. For you weigh men down with
burdens hard to bear, and you yourselves
will not even touch the burdens when one
of your fingers. You wicked hypocrites.
You tell people to do stuff you don't
do. What are you? For you build the
tombs of the prophets, you but your
fathers killed them. So you're witnesses
and approve the deeds of your fathers
because it was they who killed them and
you build their tombs. You know what he
just said? You murdered the prophets.
You are murderers. You are killers of
the prophets.
Can you imagine Jesus coming in your
house calling you stupid, foolish,
that your inside is full of filth,
you're hypocrites, and you are the
killers of the prophets. And he says
that in your own home. And he says it to
all your friends.
See it
time and a place for everything.
For this reason also those of God said,
"I will send to them prophets and
apostles. Some of them they will kill
and some they will persecute." He's
saying, "Look, you're going to end up
killing more prophets, even me."
So that the blood of all the prophets
shed since the foundation of the world
may be charged against the generation.
From the blood of Abel to the blood of
Zechariah who was killed between the
altar and the house of God. Yes, I tell
you, it shall be charged against the
generation. What do you scholars of the
law? For you have taken away the key of
knowledge. You yourselves do not enter
and you hinder those who are entering.
You're going to hell and you're damning
people to hell with your false teaching.
Right.
This Jesus
gets you excited, doesn't he? This Jesus
is a bold warrior, a lion, and he's
perfect. So, he knows the time to rebuke
and insult you and time to show you love
and patience. It's not either or. It's
all of the above. It's just being in
tune to spirit. Know when to be harsh
and when to be kind,
right?